(whirring)
(music playing)
(computer alert beeping)
Ab, Ab, Ab-- No
joke, today is the day
we become Abbi and Ilana,
the boss bitches
we are in our minds.
Are you with me?
Yeah, I'm with
you, awesome.
Are you--
Is that the whole thing?
Obviously I have a plan.
Tonight we are going to see a
secret pop-up Lil Wayne concert
at Bowery Ballroom.
I can't, I'm so broke.
No excuses, girl.
I'm getting big ol' balls
of mozzarella today.
Chea-- Get it!
Chea-- Harder.
You're gonna have to speak
in English for me.
I am getting my paycheck today
and I can spot you, bitch!
I wish that I could,
but I am so close to finishing
season one of "Damages,"
and I made, this,
like, amazing cashew stir-fry
for the week, so I'm
actually pretty booked.
Stir-fry?
Can I talk to the Abbi
who stole a van?
Ab, you're so stuck
in your little routine.
I bet you schedule when
you jack off.
Schedule when I ja--
(exhales deeply)
Oh, my God.
Is that Lincoln?
Yep.
Is he inside
of you?
Yep.
I'm just
keeping him warm.
All right-- Let's just set
some ground rules here
for everybody involved.
I don't want to
see you have sex.
Let's try and
avoid that.
Lincoln, you seem well.
Thank you-- I've been
doing this no-bread diet
and it's pretty good.
It's been working.
All right--
I'm gonna head out, then.
Peace, bye.
That was hot--
That was cool.
That was like a threesome,
in a way.
Uh, Ilana,
what are we doing?
Are we just having sex,
hooking up?
Are we dating?
What is this?
This is purely
physical.
Why does this
always happen to me?